[Musique]
jackson une ville paisible en plein
coeur du mississippi
rien ne semble perturber ses 150 mille
habitants
[Musique]
à part cette petite clinique
rogen vous serez jugés devant dieu crise
militants pro vie au médecin qui vient à
peine d'arriver à la seule clinique
d'avortement de l'état
les médecins viennent d'autres états et
se relaient la clinique n'a pas eu de
médecin régulier depuis dix ans pour des
raisons de sécurité un peu plus loin
basile chose un facteur à la retraite
tient fermement sa pancarte anti
avortement
quand ils ont libéré les camps de
concentration dit il les gens disaient
qu'ils ne savaient pas les gens doivent
savoir un shooting qu'ils tuent des
bébés de l'ua curieux bézieux
chaque jour c'est l'état de siège devant
cette clinique les manifestants ne
peuvent franchir la frontière mais
stationnaire
un va-et-vient continu elles sont des
dizaines du mississippi mais aussi du
texas de la louisiane venus se faire
avorter le nombre de patientes a presque
doublé soit 300 par mois depuis qu'il ya
des restrictions dans les autres états
escorté par des bénévoles comme et pis
étudiante en médecine qui vient dé
soutenir deux à trois fois par semaine
et servir de rempart entre elles et les
manifestants
ils peuvent me crier dessus toute la
journée dit elle ça ne me dérange pas
par contre je ne les laisserai pas
approcher nos patientes
cette clinique est au coeur d'une
bataille judiciaire aux états unis et la
cour suprême doit trancher mairie
ziegler a signé plusieurs livres sur
l'avortement aux états unis les droits
acquis sont en train de s'étioler dit
elle
on a le droit de choisir de se faire
avorter aux états unis dit elle avant la
viabilité du foetus c'est à dire entre
21 et 24 semaines quand le foetus ne
peut survivre en dehors de l'utérus se
met pour défendre la loi du mississippi
dit elle la cour suprême devrait dire
que le droit d'avorter peut être
supprimé même avant la viabilité du
foetus ça va être un changement
significatif dans la loi
en attendant que la cour suprême tranche
la clinique elle poursuit ses activités
le même jour un coq et bénévole depuis
neuf ans de guerre
les lois sont de pire en pire dit elle
est plus difficile a bloqué 2
les militants pro vie sont plus
déterminés que jamais dit-elle surtout
depuis 2000 16 depuis dans notre chambre
ils se sont plus puissants
et tous les moyens sont bons
après la colère ce sont les prières
la clinique fait jouer de la musique
pour étouffer les sons l'extérieur
mon
[Musique]
les militants apporter à leur tour des
haut parleurs
on tient le coup des rangers légèrement
excédé il ya toujours des manifestants
cassel nous passionne
certaines d'entre elles pleurent d'iter
si la cour suprême donne raison au
mississippi et renverse l'arrêt roe
contre wade c'est le feu vert pour
chaque état selon les experts qui
veulent restreindre voire interdire
l'accès à l'avortement au moins vingt
états sont sur le qui-vive et attendre
la décision de la cour suprême avant
d'agir
éventuellement dit elle la cour suprême
va donner le droit aux états d'agir sur
la question de l'avortement
et comme il ya 50 ans devant cette cour
suprême les deux camps s'affrontent
brandissant les mêmes pancartes les
libertés des femmes est en jeu scandent
les manifestants
une fois de plus les deux amériques
s'entre déchirent et pour beaucoup c'est
aussi la crédibilité de la cour suprême
qui est en jeu